Fate schifo merosi tradimenti
e nonostante questo l'ho sempre perdonato perché io lo amo
io ho un grande difetto che mi piacciono tantissimo le donne
il mio punto debole, è una cosa che
non riesco a resistere
Questa esperienza mi servirà a capire se Oronzo
guarirà mai da questa famosa malattia delle donne che dice di avere
solo al cento per cento che sbaglierò però tanto so che lei
Mi perdonerà. Non temo nessuno dei singoli perché so' troppo bello
non mi fanno paura tutti sti palestri sti cosi
io so' bello così
Valentina
Ho un video per te
Neanche con me fa così al mare neanche con me gioca così
non ho ancora trovato la donna della mia vita dopo dieci anni che stiamo insieme ma stiamo scherzando?
Che schifo che mi fa
La devo ancora trovare? Ma stiamo scherzando? il mondo gli ho perdonato, il mondo Filì
Oronzo
Ho un video per te
Filippo
solo una cosa voglio dire mo' inizio a giocare, non me ne fotte più niente
mo' torno essere l'Oronzo di sei anni fa
mo mi diverto perché per adesso mi sono trattenuto ho fatto il bravo mo' divento brutto
Perché l'amo troppo perché in questi giorni ho capito che
che mi manca assai e mai in dieci anni mai in dieci anni mi era successo di pensare questa cosa
Queste cose proprio le sorvolavo il ti amo, lei, tanto pensavo ma chi me la tocca
Buonasera ciao
Niente mi devi dire?
Tu mi hai fatto venire qua, no? in dieci anni ho mai visto quelle cose mai
cosa mi sta succedendo? cosa ti sta succedendo, dimmi
Perché tu? tu non hai fatto niente, vero orò?
no zero
Quindi l'hai fatto per vendetta questa cosa uscire con quella persona e farmi soffrire che sai che poi io soffro
lascia stare un attimo quello che ho fatto io ti sto chiedendo lo sai che cosa mai fatto passare per 10 anni
eh, quante cose ti ho perdonato?
Lo sai qual è il problema ah? ho capito che ti amo follemente
ah
Tu però lo sai quello che ho visto io?
Quello che hai fatto quello che hai detto soprattutto quello che hai detto
Ti ho sempre detto che quello che vedi non è
Non è come sembra
ah quello che vedo non è come sembra ah
ti hanno detto di dire così? no però, non c'è un discorso dietro, eh?
tutto un discorso dietro, eh? che io mica sono arrivato qui e ho detto quanta figa! c'è un discorso dietro, che, eh...
e queste due vite? che c'entra! due vite nel senso che lo sai io ho due vite: una con te
che stiamo sempre insieme e poi c'è invece la vita quella
che non è che per forza
con un'altra donna, è quella mia vita un po'
spericolata una vita che è
la vita è una orò!
la tua vita e io devo farne parte
il problema è che in dieci anni di vita mai ho pensato
che avevo fatto delle minchiate mai ho pensato a quanto mi manca valentina
è tanto dicevo è li, mi aspetta a casa
ah, e tu così ragioni!
lo so ma prima ragionavo così
ah, perchè sei cambiato?
si
e l'occhiolino?
perché orò, perché?
eh, occhiolino, occhiolino, và, mi è venuto un tick
Lo sai e lo sai che ho questa malattia delle donne
dopo dieci anni di che non ha ancora trovato la donna della tua vita orò
ma normale sei?
a differenza tua il mio era uno scherzo
per farti capire come mi sento tutte le volte che mi hai fatto soffrire
e secondo te questa cosa mi ha fatto bene?
secondo te conoscendomi io sarei uscita subito con un ragazzo conoscendomi
mi sei mancata tantissimo!
io ho proprio capito che
ti volevo avere vicino
a è no caro mio, troppo tardi perché tu ti vuoi divertire e vuoi avere me non esiste proprio
valentina torni a casa da sola o con il tuo fidanzato oronzo lo stronzo
Da sola
Da sola?
Veramente da sola dormi?
Mi sono stancata orò
mi sono stancata di soffrire devo pensare a me stessa non pensare che non ti amo più però mi sono stancata
da sola a casa torni?
Io avevo pensato invece che volevi tornare a casa con me, avevo pensato
tu non mi rigiri più oro
Io ho una dignità oro me ne torno a casa
Posso andarmene?